hi there my name is reto Meier and i'm
ian ni-lewis and we're going to be
taking a look at the technology behind a
device profile switcher apps Tasker NFC
task launcher and profile widget so
we'll stick around to find out what
features and technical tips and tricks
it takes to make a device profile app
today on the App clinic so so we're
going to take a look at that these three
apps today and they're all fairly
similar in what they're trying to do
which is excellent because it makes it
much easier for us to talk about the
technology that really makes them great
it's also great because we really relate
to these apps I think that these apps
although they have an appeal to everyone
I think everyone would like the
functionality that these apps provide
but it turns out that the people that
actually use them or mostly hackers and
software engineers it's true and that's
actually something which we're going to
see as we go through each of these apps
we can almost see who the target
audience ends up being and so I think
much like the evolution of most
technologies and mobile phones most
recently you sort of start off with
something that appeals to a kind of a
geek crowd and then if you create
something which just anyone can use to
make their life easier it's going to
become massively popular so we're going
to look at how these apps are
approaching those problems and how we
think they can do a good job of taking
that one step further so we're going to
start off by looking at the standard
feature so these are the things that all
of these apps can do so this is
basically the the key core functionality
that we would consider that you need in
order to make a device profile switching
app yeah let's talk about what a device
profile swimming or fishing app it's an
idol it is definitely that well it's
just because I call them task apps ok
let's go um toss you know what I don't
call them anything they trick the
problem you call them 10 may be there
auto apps I don't yeah the thing about
device profile is I think the
terminology comes from the idea of
having your device in a completely
different state for certain things and
we certainly introduced that concept
when we started looking into docs and
the ideas you'd have one profile when
you're undocked versus another profile
while you're docked but these ads that
we're looking at today go far beyond
that and I think it's it's almost hard
to talk about a specific profile because
there are multiple overlapping things
that each app can do absolutely but the
core of it is we're going to change
something in the system or possibly just
do something in the system and you
execute an action when the conditions of
the system change exactly and so the
idea here is that rather than having
sort of a single toggle you're able to
say I'm at home I'm at work I am
entering a meeting whatever your profile
case is and execute a whole bunch of
different settings changes or launch a
bunch of apps as as Ian says basically
perform a series of actions in relation
to that change in environment so they
can all change the volume and ringtones
they can all change brightness they can
all modify your connectivity settings as
well some of the apps i think task in
particular go significantly further than
that but these are sort of the core
things that i think anyone downloading
one of these apps is going to want to be
able to do mute the volume change your
ringtone alter the screen brightness
based on time of day or location and in
addition to that although it doesn't
really fit into the profile idea i think
i would add sending alerts and
notifications SMS is things like that
absolutely and so okay so these three
apps like we say they have these things
in common and I kind of like to think of
them as three variations on a theme I'm
going to see this as we go through
Tasker is kind of like a self-driving
car spend a lot of time setting it up
once it's going you just sit there and
it does everything for you know I wonder
if that's a really good analogy or or if
it's going to resonate because while
everyone can understand the experience
of getting in a self-driving car I mean
everyone's been driven by someone only
people like you and I know what it takes
to set up a self-driving car this is
very true as in the morning yeah I know
right I mean you gotta you gotta plug
things in we shouldn't go into right NFC
task launcher is kind of like driving an
auto it does most of the hard work for
you but you still need to initiate the
action you still need to do something
and you still have some element of
profile widget goes the other way you
basically have to initiate it yourself
entirely choose which widgets to click
which profile you want to switch to so
you have to kind of be conscious of that
rather than just being able to use
particular location so let's talk a
little bit about what we want from the
ad so we've talked about what they can
do for what they all should do and how
they sort of very at a very high level
so what are the things that you want to
see in an app like this for it to be
your go-to well I think the most
important thing that I want is for it to
be able to control everything I don't
want any part of my system to remain
untouched by this app now of course that
as we talked about yesterday we had a
long conversation about permissions and
how wanting to control everything
imposes some really interesting
restrictions and responsibilities on the
developer of the app but I want it to do
everything I don't want there to be
anything that I can do the phone that
this app can't because I want it to be
an agent or proxy for me I also want to
make sure that it can combine multiple
events and multiple actions with
multiple conditions because the sort of
profile that I can use to tell you that
i'm at work for instance unless it's got
machine learning along the lines of
Google now only next year's version well
now it probably doesn't know that I'm at
work it probably doesn't know that I'm
in a meeting I need to be able to tell
it that yeah when I'm attached to this
Wi-Fi network during these hours of the
day I and you know possibly some other
conditions that's when I need to be not
disturbed or that's when I can accept
text messages so I need to be able to
push all of those into one container and
some several of the apps that we looked
at have this functionality but only in
the pro version mmm so that's something
to look for absolutely now the other
thing that you need I think you
mentioned is these things are really
difficult to set up yes they and that's
I think the cool thing here is that it's
something which if you describe the
functionality to people is kind of
obvious and as being things like this
built into mobile phone operating
systems for a long time on and off
on this notion of being able to you know
click a button change a setting in your
at home at work you know receiving calls
not receiving calls I think the
challenge has always been presenting
this in a way that just regular people
can use at the moment and we'll see it
varies for each of these apps but at the
moment you've got that tendency to feel
like you're having to program the phone
alright and that's what you want to get
away from so when we say easy to use
what we mean is easy to configure
especially the actual use case I think
for all three is pretty straightforward
but the configuration is is the trick
and so we really want to make it as easy
as possible and that kind of relates to
the to the last point yeah there's
really two ways that you can make this
easy to use you can egg you can either
make it very easy to program I which if
you figure out how to do that um let me
know yeah that could be because yeah
there's there's a ton of money this is a
you know I used to program games and one
of the things that we would always say
is boy I don't want a program all this
gameplay it seems like the designers
should be able to do that and so
multiple projects this happened to me I
wasn't always the one calling the shots
but you make a scripting language and
give it to the designers and they're
like oh thanks and then they come to you
and say hey can you write this script
and you realize wow i just spent a huge
amount of time making this scriptable
and i'm going to have to write all the
code descriptive and that's the feeling
that I get with these apps is you know
for a software engineer or someone who's
used to thinking in terms of code these
are very easy to use I mean some of them
are more cumbersome than others
navigation wise some of them are
prettier than others but the concepts
are easy at the same time for most
people I think it's going to be like
programming a VCR which is you know you
you want to do it you know what you want
but you're never gonna do it if you
never gonna figure that out right it'll
be one person in the house who figures
it out and that's it exactly can you set
up no one person in the extended family
and you don't want to be that guy I
don't want to be that guy so let's take
a tip from the VCR well you remember
that this was very very difficult until
things like TiVo came along and what
they were doing was leveraging the
information that was on the internet
community um to help you know instead of
saying I want to program this amount of
time you could say yeah I want to watch
this show yeah which is always what you
want to do right no one just randomly
wants to record half an hour of
television sometime on Friday night
there is a theme there is something on
that they want to record usually yeah
generally so it turns out the best way
to solve this is to have a community
repository so I can go to the Internet
and say oh yeah someone else had a
problem where they don't want to receive
alarm notifications between 10pm and 6am
and yet they still want their their
clock to be able to send them an alarm
and I pull down that code and install it
into the task application that I'm using
and boom I got what I wanted and I
didn't have to learn how to program the
thing so the ease of use is important
but you can get away with less ease of
use if you have a better repository of
community scripts the people can very
easily browse and install exactly this
gets to one of the points which we tend
to make again and again it's one of
these recurring themes is you want to
make it really easy for people to see
the value of your app within the first
30 seconds of installing your app so
they can press a couple of buttons as
soon as the app is opened and say ah oh
ok cool so this is now going to mute my
volume between you know after nine
o'clock at night before six in the
morning and maximize my alarm let's
that's perfect that's that's going to be
useful for me I can use this right away
and it gets their minds thinking as to
how else they may use it if all you're
presenting them with is a blank canvas
you know hit plus two to create a new
action and then you've got this massive
array of controls for literally
everything if the app is doing the right
thing is daunting it's like I don't know
how I would even want to use this and
they'll move on so make that initial
action of learning the app and
understanding how to use it as simple
and easy as possible and need a little
knowledge of that so let's take a trip
to the top of the power curve and
possibly the bottom of the ease-of-use
occur with tasker okay as you know a
feature graphic is a great way to grab
people's attention and let them know in
a nutshell what your app is about Tasker
doesn't have a feature graphic know
which is very sad so I've gone ahead and
tried to take the liberty of creating a
quick mock-up now you know I'm not an
artist and so this doesn't have the the
flare of let's say a Roman Nurik design
but well I think it captures almost
perfectly what the average user can
expect when they start tasker yeah you
like that that's pretty good oh yeah all
thats got below it's you know it's got
big text which you like yeah I think
it's representative yeah and a beautiful
photo absolutely only 14 night stock
photo credits the point is the point
that I'm trying to make I'm yeah I'm
being a little I kavitha it's just like
an airliner it it might be the best way
to get you where you want to go but
there's a good chance that you're not
actually qualified to take the wheel and
fly it yourself and I think that's the
way most people are gonna feel about
tasker and that's the thing about toph
3d is it is an app which which does
everything literally everything but it
is a little like sitting down in the
console a 747 the first time you open it
up bingo you spent a little more time
looking at this app didn't you solo yeah
I yeah it's it's a great app and oh look
at that ah nice okay all right I so
tester is is tackling a really difficult
job the mission of the tasker app is to
let you define what your phone does in
any specific set of circumstances and it
wants to let you define those
circumstances as precisely as possible
and give you as many things to do in
those circumstances as possible so for
instance you might want to turn off
Wi-Fi when you leave your house or turn
off bluetooth when your battery gets low
or even and this is something Tasker can
do automatically respond to text
messages when you're in the car it's
ended
text saying sorry i'm driving it can't
respond to you which i think is awesome
that's very nice yeah I actually use
tasker for several months myself I
didn't I don't think I'm as big of a fan
as these of these apps as you are I have
no idea why I think it's just because i
have very irregular habits i think
that's the key to these apps is they
presume that you are going to want to
respond to the same situations in the
same way right at the same general time
yeah exactly where as i am irregular
lazy and sort of you know odd in my
habits and free spirit right exactly and
you're practically British so depending
on where you're coming from you'll have
a different experience with this but
there was a time in my life when our
dear employer decided to turn on alarms
for all calendar invites that came from
our corporate email Center which meant
that we got alarm set on all of our
holiday reminders they get woken up at
midnight going oh it's midnight it's
Christmas Eve don't forget to sleep in
tomorrow yeah that was a good time so I
specifically use tasker to just turn off
tomm calendar notifications between like
11 p.m. and 1am and that worked out
pretty well nice uh but when you think
about it Tasker is really offering an
environment for programming your phone
so it's not surprising that most of the
people that love this app are software
engineers and using it feels like
software engineering in fact you can
actually write android apps in Tasker
we're not we're not going to cover that
functionality that one's that's for a
different time and we talked about on
device ides yeah someday okay fun so
it's a very powerful program and this is
really the problems with great power
comes great usability issues my
complaint with tasker though is not that
it's difficult I expected that it's that
it's more difficult than it has to be so
let's switch to the giant phone and oh
and we can swap places
yeah yeah because you know well crazy
well yeah you gonna trick yourself over
on my awesome well I said wireless mics
and everybody said no it's crazy and I
said I'm buying him anyway and then they
sucked okay so now after last week's
issues some people said that we
shouldn't use the giant phone that it's
too much phone for us to handle that a
smaller more discreet phone might suit
us better to them I say witness the
power of our fully operational giant
phone which I can handle just fine okay
that's disturbing yes Oh leaving aside
the the issues that we have with
navigation legacy buttons and just
general Android design guideline issues
let's just focus on the meat of tasker
let's let's actually define a task so
when i start up I the first thing I see
is three tabs as profiles tasks and
scenes now as a user I'm thinking to
myself okay I know I want to do tasks at
least that's what I thought right now I
think that other people might say oh I
wanted to find it a profile right it
depends on how you look at it yeah
depends on how familiar you are with the
programs and the the terminology that
goes around it there's not always
obvious to me whether what's a task
what's a profile right now it turns out
in Tasker a profile is a set of context
that contain tasks okay now you'll
notice there is no context button
instead there is a scenes button which
actually sounded like it contd like oh
maybe if I'm in this scene perhaps I
have become I have become an actor in
the scene when i exit stage left oh we
are not actors on the stage of life I
will be pursued by a bear so acting I so
I immediately went to scenes because
that made sense um now it gives me a
helpful pop-up which essentially says
please do not press this button again
all right why did you press the button
stop pressing it yes but it turns out
that seems are actually the GUI designer
for writing your own applications in the
tasker design language cool before it is
cool cut that up as oh yeah I wanted to
point out a modal dialog please don't do
models rights particularly when it's a
modal dialog popping up over an empty
screen so I mean this there is nothing
here so if you want to display some
information that's the place to put it
not on a proper well and that's that's
really the issue that we're going to see
over and over again is that this is a
very modal dialog based application and
I think part of it you know especially
when you look at the buttons I think you
can see that this was definitely
designed in the you know the Clare era
and that used to be I think a better way
of doing things than it is now I think
we have much better design language now
than we did one was at that time it was
quite ambiguous you know it's really up
to you and if you wanted your apt to
look good you really needed to do it all
yourself and I can say that they've put
some effort in here to try and make it
look better than the stop gingerbread
yes yes stuff unfortunately now it
starts to look a little dated and look I
understand we all definitely understand
why people have been reluctant to update
their app with every single version of
Android but since hollow since androids
three things have been pretty consistent
with added new things but if you create
an app which is fun you know consistent
with those design guidelines I think you
find something which is going to look
good for a while become so I'm really
excited to see what Roman has to say
about this but I will point out that
there are some great apps on google play
right now that sign a little bit more in
this area now I haven't found anything
with the power of tasker but for
instance there's a an app called
automated which uses almost an identical
paradigm but it allows me to swipe
between the different pages and as I do
different actions where where Tasker
uses modal dialogues automate it uses
drop downs and it uses what do we
all those things where they sort of open
up and women expanding exactly exactly
so they use expansions one really
obvious place for instance is when you
choose a location on automated then it
expands a map view directly underneath
the piece of script that you're working
on whereas here you it actually takes
you to a completely different screen all
right you just provide you the context
without breaking your workflow exactly
like that again you know not a huge big
deal just a you know some things that
could be polished there the important
thing is helping people to understand
how these things actually work now these
little modal dialogues that pop up are
certainly better than nothing but could
be better now it is pretty obvious
though what I need to do to add a
profile I don't really want to click the
plus button down here I probably would
have rather had it in the list but you
know that's a that's a quibble I do like
that the new profile name is optional
great I can click right past it without
having to to think of something to type
in and have all of my profiles named qwe
so the first context is going to give me
i I'm sorry it's naming it first context
but he's giving me some options for
context and this is essentially the
conditions under which you're going to
run so for instance I'm going to want to
be let's say during a particular time
time entry is is painful more our fault
than theirs it's alpha but we fix it so
please hide a shame exactly so okay I'll
say it's in this and then I'm going to
do a task at that particular time again
optional name thank you and a task
contains I actions and then actions go
into a huge amount we're now one nice
thing is if this is everything right
everything you could want to do here
exactly and it's categorized so that's
that's good i mean there's there's
probably you know over a hundred options
here and i don't have to look at all of
them at once so you know maybe i want to
you know do a particular task or I
didn't reach anything else's there are
there are innocent else's all over it
really is kind of a pro
language for yes coming your phone
rather than programming apps there are
in fact even variables that you can set
etc etc so the Tasca guys or guy I'm not
sure how many people are involved but
they're basically trying to implement a
GUI based programming language form
altering your phone's behavior on the
fly exactly and that's apparently hard
that's not really surprising it's a
relatively difficult activity so I
really are asking them to say look we
love the functionality of your jumbo jet
but we'd like to have just sort of a
steering wheel or maybe a brake pedal
and an accelerator well this is where I
think the task you could make the most
difference is in having a usable
repository they can be the first thing
that I see so instead of seeing the
ability to program things coming up
initially I'd rather see a bunch of
stuff that other people have programmed
this is the way a lot of people learn
how to write code in a new life serving
you it certainly is for me I'm not so
much the read all the API Doc's first
before I get started I more like let me
download a sample app that does
something in the vague vicinity of what
I want and I'm just going to mess with
oh I think it's telling that that for
instance I you know the JavaScript guys
we work with they say yeah they'll never
obfuscate source code because otherwise
how would anyone learn JavaScript
exactly and I answer no one learns
JavaScript so hey you know I don't want
to get too far into it but the rabbit
hole to the the the other thing that I
wanted to bring up though was well
actually let me finish by adding some
random AXA okay so they do have
conditions on everything but it makes
the defining a task a little bit
difficult because you need to define a
essentially an event now they call them
I contexts and they can be stateful in
the sense that that you can enter and
exit them but you basically have to say
in response to this event do this task
but only if this other thing and that's
how most of the things are structured
and some of the other things we looked
at were a
little bit more explicit as far as the
conditionals right now you'd actually
have to burrow in to each conditional to
see which one actually applied got you
okay so we could talk about Tasker for
hours and hours it's a wonderful program
you can definitely check it out but
let's go ahead and move on to something
that's maybe a little bit easier to
configure yeah it's a little it's a
little easy way before we do I just
wanted to do a really quick call out
thank you for blocking the photo of me
one of the things about an app like
perfect it's like I'm whoa what's the
photo what's being overlaid one of the
beautiful things about tasker and a lot
of these apps is that they function
based on location grateful whether
you're at home or at work or whatever
else and so it's really really important
in that context to be as efficient as
possible in your location updates
because this is just something which is
going to help you know give you a
shortcut no one wants to sacrifice hours
of battery life to be able to save
themselves two or three seconds of
clicking things so I have a deep dive
into location on the Android developers
blog which you can check out which can
give you some of the details there
there's also a section on the tasker
wiki which by the way so it's not that
they don't have a community it's that
they have a community with a wiki where
you can download XML and presumably load
it into task or somehow so it's it's
it's not that it's not friendly it's
just that it's not friendly for normal
people yeah yeah so they have a section
called location without tears which also
goes over some of this and has some very
interesting Tasker specific info perfect
alright so let's so let's have a look at
the next step which is NFC task launcher
from tags stand now they have as you can
see a lovely feature graphic gives you
an idea of how it's going to work it's
kind of artistic I kind of like it don't
know if you necessarily need to have the
phone on there but in this instance it
kind of makes sense because it's showing
how the app gets used another see tag
there you hold your phone over that's
how the magic happens now I actually
have used this app quite a bit I had a
big set of suggestions from my initial
experience working with the app getting
everything configured and since I had
everything can
the way I wanted to I haven't really had
to go through that process again so I
opened up the app just to confirm my
thinking and it turns out that they're
fixed pretty much everything I was good
being reto Meier isn't it I don't even
think I told him I'd just you know it's
I think we've blogged about it and they
just read your blog that's awesome yeah
that's possible but well it's wonderful
for me to see like the big questions i
had was particularly around things like
navigation getting started a lot of
things that we've already talked about
and and they've actually fix a lot of
what i was asking for so it has a little
bit of context the way i use this app I
actually talked a little bit about it
and when I do a blog post about how i
modded my Prius to be able to use my
Nexus 7 I love that you drive a Prius
that's so San Francisco if you're gonna
move right I I on the other hand drive a
Mack truck with windshield washers that
squirt West Texas light crude nice yeah
so that way you can get that rose
colored you know tint to the world well
you know you're not going to kill many
birds in your Prius that's all I'm
saying well no you have to really aim it
yeah so huh this is how i use the app
every day so in my car as you can see
there about a tablet there's an NFC
sticker stuck on that mount so when I
put the tablet in there it turns on
navigation it turns on Wi-Fi and
connects to the hotspot which is enabled
when I put my phone into the center
console so again I've got a sticker
stuck underneath the other little tray
for my mobile phone and that turns on
the hot spot for my Nexus 7 it also
turns on the nexus 7 musics so as soon
as I sit down put it there I start
getting my music which is lovely when i
get to work i have a NFC tag stuck under
the bottom of my desk got a little X
marked on my desk I put my phone there
it turns off my volume you know connects
to the offers Wi-Fi and with a bunch of
other stuff so you're they get it
through your desk yeah it's like an inch
of I guess really really light wood but
it gets through which is nice at home
where where I put my wallet and keys
again I have an NFC tag so I just pop my
phone against that connects to the home
Wi-Fi you know does all of the other
things I need at home and then the last
thing is I have a little coaster which I
stuck in NFC
to sits next to my bed boom pop it there
when I go to sleep mutes everything
turns on the alarm etc etc so it's
really automating a lot of the stuff
that I do sort of every day and once
you've set it up once you never really
need to think about it it's genius and
actually I tried to do this very same
thing I ran into a few problems I
realized that actually this app works a
lot better if you're consistently sober
so that was an issue there's an issue
right there is that but also the one
thing I noticed and this really isn't a
an issue with this app per se it's more
the operating system in general I would
love to see us at this is the app needs
to be installed so for instance I
thought oh I'll put a Wi-Fi sticker for
my guest network next to the door that
was one of the things the app suggested
then I went to the sticker and it turns
out first thing it needs to do is
download the app because there's no
general set up a Wi-Fi NFC intent she's
a shame which in a way is a shame
because it would be really useful but it
would also make this Apple s useful so
you know it's chicken and egg it's you
will want to stick like a barcode on to
the NFC tag so you can scan the barcode
which will install the app which will
then let you use the tag but that well
no no it does actually install the app
but the problem for me was well if I'm
bringing somebody over to use my guest
network and the first thing they need to
do is install an app how are they gonna
get to the network to install ya gonna
be a challenge right you know I mean you
might say via mobile network okay this
is the Bay Area yeah what if they're on
AT&T yeah and in there other than that's
all right why in my house yes they are
yeah I guess this is particularly useful
if you happen to have a nexus q so you
need to get on to the right network so
you could have the tag there and you
don't have to worry so much about sort
of Wi-Fi in general but for specific
Wi-Fi mm-hmm anyway we're weird rather
holy again so I want to move on real
quick so happily this now we're gonna
have to switch we did this really well
yeah you should go in front all right
excellent yay uh huh huh so like I said
I had a whole bunch of suggestions for
these guys but as it turns out where I
can go through this pretty quickly
because most of what I wanted them to do
they now due to the Welcome is really
nice this I think works really well this
is this is what happens when you load
the app for the first time you have a
little welcome dialogue it explains how
to use the app what it's there for
it's not modal it's not going to stop
you from doing anything else and you can
dismiss it after you've read it the
first time so I actually really like
this is an introduction to a nap I think
it works really really well once you do
dismiss this you have pre-existing
suggestions you have all of these
profiles which have descriptive names so
you go this is this is for work this is
for home this is for you know daytime
nighttime these these things which you
can immediately say okay well yeah that
sounds like exactly what I want to do I
downloaded this app so that I could shut
down everything when I when I went to
sleep and so I'm going to choose this
and see what happens and then once you
select any of those you can then
continue to modify them but it gives you
a start it gives you as a user an idea
for how am I going to use this and what
do I need to do in order to get sort of
the obvious things working so we'll jump
back to the giant phone and allah i'll
bring up NFC task launcher perfect so
it's all it's all got a really nice
modern a hollow type you i still
customized it's got this sort of orange
theme which is similar in color to the
to the gingerbread orange but nicer it's
so oh yeah you know that different shade
they're consistent with there are more
creamsicle less pumpkin indeed indeed
and you can see here you've got all
these locations so these are popular
tags which people have created and
configured you've got your nice icons
and that was one of the things I wanted
to say once you've created your own tags
they're listed here under my tags but
you lose the cool icons like I would
like to be able to have that as a
shortcut it's a small thing but it just
makes it a little bit easier
particularly if you have a lot of these
to be able to easily recognize them if
you want to edit them now of course
you're not actually going to be using
the UI that much because it's one of
those you set it up once you leave it
forever type scenarios so if we go
through will create a tag based on
something else so create a Wi-Fi network
that's probably a bad example because we
need to actually have a Wi-Fi network
will go home so it's going to change my
ring type to normal and turn on Wi-Fi
that makes sense and when you get to
this to this point you can almost get a
little bit confusing so we're going to
say save and write so I like that
they've got the confirmation up the top
here that that's great and at this point
it gets a little bit confusing so this
is the point where you would put you
or phone against the tag to record this
wish once you do it will you know why
bro I tell you it's done which is great
but then to finish you kind of have
these two options on the one hand at the
top left it says finish and on the top
right it says done if you keep finish it
goes back which is correct because it's
actually the upper fortin's that I'm
clicking so you do have to write down
but I just found that a little bit
confusing you almost don't want to
another resistors page is called finish
yes it's that we can it has an upper
fortin's yes but it has also a done
button yes and importantly here this is
do they both do the same thing No if you
hit the upper for dance it goes back and
that's kind of important in it so okay
up in terms of android means don't go to
a sibling go to a parent now these are
basically what you're going through here
is a wizard and a wizard is a horizontal
sibling flow you're moving from you know
equal stages along the path yeah so back
should take you back up should take you
out of this workflow and in this case
it's basically the equivalent of cancel
so you probably don't actually want to
do and uh performance here you want to
have basically a save and right or I
think cut remember the name that that
Roman has been using for it but the
alternative way you basically have a
save and a cancel right up the top here
so those are the two things that you can
do and it emits type of them yeah
exactly like a commute or cancel at any
point and in general if you're going to
do a use a wizard the very best way to
do it that the users like is just use a
few pagers so you know because it is
weird to have a verb in your action i'll
buy ya annual at a bar so but having
that as as a particular tab on a wizard
especially a wizard that you can swipe
through which is becoming a far more
interesting and understood action than a
back button honestly I mean you'd think
a back button is the easiest thing in
the world yeah but I've seen people with
the back button right there trying to
swipe yeah because as soon as you start
thinking in a horizontal flow you want
to be able to swipe a viewpager style
exactly and that's the biggest it's
still one of the biggest challenges like
and particularly if you're using a view
pager to swipe between things which
aren't necessarily contextually
identical
if I swipe along this main page it tells
you where you can buy tags which is a
great feature because the first thing
you go is that's great but we delete the
tags from right this is nice and you've
got popular tags might take some
statistics to tell you how many actions
you've performed how much time popular
tags that sort of our community
repository can you upload your own but
i'm not sure i don't know that you can
upload your own so i'm not sure whether
they mean popular as in used by a lot of
people or popular as in asked for by a
lot of people so they don't have a
community repository would be wonderful
to see that but the trick here is that
when I'm in by tags or if I'm over in
statistics mentally my context to switch
I'm no longer looking at tags I'm
looking at stats and so my temptation is
more frequently than i'd like to admit
to hit back to go back to my tags and
then I exit the app and I'm angry and
frustrated so that's I don't necessarily
have a great solution but it's a risk of
having contextually independent items
all on the same view pager right so
again we're short on time so I don't
want to go into too much depth here the
one thing I did want to point out so the
difference between this and task post a
score is fully automated you set up your
context and then you leave it in your
pocket it does it all for you right this
you do need to hit the NFC tag which is
nice the disadvantage here of course is
that you have to be conscious of it you
have to have a tag in the right place
you have to manually do the the tapping
rather than just having automatically
the advantage is that you don't need to
have any services running it's really
efficient nothing needs to be running in
the background the app can be completely
gone and once you hit an NFC tag it's
still going to wake up and you know do
what it needs to do which is nice so how
would you go about building something
like this well you need to learn a lot
about NFC really the key here is you
need to learn to listen for tags and try
and be as specific as possible as to the
type of data that you're trying to
loosen for so that you're not can
colliding with other apps which are also
listening for NFC data there's a couple
of really good google i/o talks which
you can check out one from 2011 with
nick belly and jeff hamilton which
really give a great introduction to how
NFC works how you would build an app
that works in similar way to this and
then last year there was another
follow-up session to that up close and
personal which talked a little bit more
about Android Beam but again gave more
of an update into how NFC can be used
for apps like this so I'm going to buzz
really quickly through a profile widget
as well so this is the kind of the fully
automatic or the fully manual version I
suppose it's mm-hmm you have to know
exactly what you're switching to so with
the right so it's got the task propanol
the detection part exactly exactly it's
probably one of the most simplistic of
the three apps that we looked at but in
some ways it's almost a positive because
it's there is should be a much smaller
learning curve to get going indeed well
especially as we talked about design
deciding what profile i'm in is actually
a really interesting machine learning
task which a lot of users wouldn't be
able to program even if they knew how so
this is actually really attractive
exactly so you can say they've got the
nice profile graphic which is great
always like to see that and that is a
prerequisite in order to be considered
for our pure Android collection we'll
have more on soon we've got a few likely
candidates which maybe yes maybe getting
unvieled soon unveils that's not a word
and they assumed it was British maybe it
is a bit either way I don't know it mmm
we switch back sure this is awesome
alright we have like half an hour to
review these slides how to attach but
other than that so this is profile
widget so they've got a dashboard
pattern which is a bit of a shame
particularly because one of the key
things for me on all of these apps is
that they need to work well on tablets
because there are tablets with NFC and I
use those just as much as my phone so it
doesn't work quite as well it also means
that the learning curve is much higher
than it should be i started this app off
and this is the page that i get it's not
obvious to me what do I do here like
profile widget I don't really understand
how to get going and as you navigate
through the app it doesn't really get
any clearer it's it's kind of hard to
understand and I'll show you that when
we bring up the giant phone and in a
moments one thing that I really did want
to point out is they have a really nice
toast so because it's a it's all sort of
automated you plus a widget you don't
have an activity to show information you
need to use something like a toast and
they've customized their toasts really
well with a valid color or background so
it's not just sort of that general
standard generic toast which pops up so
and this is one of the few places where
a toast is truly appropriate exactly and
it's nice to see that they have used it
appropriately and printed it up as well
which is great so let's jump to the
giant phone really quickly so if we have
a look at profile widget here you can
see straight away like if we go back to
the the main page so the way it works is
you go into your profiles and then
there's activate profiles and create and
edit and what you actually want to do
for most cases is either create or edit
a profile reordering and activating a
sort of secondary functions if we go
into editing day then we end up with
this screen so we're already having to
sort of navigate deep into the innards
of the app and at this point we can do
things like change the icons modify the
sound connection and and screen so one
of the other I guess not necessarily
issues but observations about this phone
this app so it doesn't have quite the
same level of control that the others do
you can't do things you can turn on and
off Wi-Fi but you can't specify a Wi-Fi
network to connect an art for example so
it's a little bit more limited in its
functionality there as well once you
actually have it set up it creates this
really nice sir widget on the home
screen which is great again they've put
a lot of time into the design effort of
making sure that things you actually use
a lot look nice and so if I click on the
widget lets me choose a profile to
activate displays it in the nice little
toast and then changes the actual widget
so it can see what profile you're in so
the expectation here is really much more
sort of that older approach of defining
a profile for your phone where you
basically want to say night mode day
mode at home mode Wi-Fi on work whatever
it is calming people certainly get used
to that I mean we've got airplane mode
for instance demo work mode home mode so
those all makes sense and I like that
it's probably worth mentioning that
Tasker for instance and most of the
other profile apps also
offer widgets yes if that's what you're
into it's just that they they focus most
of their efforts on the more interesting
conditional stuff it was that exactly
and so I think this this there is an
itch for an app like this which makes it
much provides a much smaller simpler
subset for the most common to be eighty
percent of things which people want to
do turn off screen brightness mute mute
volume change ringtones well if if I was
trying to do this for my mom this is
exactly what i would use because i don't
want to have to do tech support for the
set of profiles and conditions that i
wrote to figure out if she's at work or
not yeah she has a problem with that I'd
rather that she just presses a button
because the code that i can write in
their script is not going to be nearly
accurate enough to cover all the cases
and if it ever fails she's not going to
be able to fix it exactly so this is
kind of nicer though the downside here
for this app is that it's simpler once
you understand how to use it but they're
learning curve to understand how you're
setting up your profiles where that
happens how you place a widget the
actual process of putting your widget on
the home screen and choosing like how
it's going to choose between the the
different profiles you've set up is a
little bit harder and less intuitive
than it should be so that's I think the
key for these guys is to really try and
make that process as simple and an easy
to to do well I think we knew this show
is going to run long because these are
such complex apps but let's go ahead and
talk a little bit now wrap it up and see
what all of these apps should be doing
absolutely so we kind of introduced this
stuff at the beginning you know we
wanted to do as much as possible we want
it to be easy to use we wanted to work
on tablets and tablets I guess this is
one which i do want to bring up because
i think they've all been designed for
phones which makes sense but you know we
really want to try and emphasize how
much people should be thinking about
doing those things and so step one is
really creating a great responsive
design so that the app is going to look
good and work great on any device that
you happen to be using it doesn't matter
what orientation you're in it doesn't
matter whether it's a tablet whether
it's a phone whatever it is it should
just adapt and work well and similarly
you want to create that great tablet
specific experience and even if you're
not planning to do anything tablet
specific it should still work you
shouldn't
have to worry that oil actually my on my
Nexus 7 it doesn't work and I have to
mount it differently in my car or paste
the NFC tag in a different place and so
really you want to optimize you know in
all ways and in fact there can be
opportunities to take it a step further
now we can see that the NFC task
launcher is providing some statistics
that sort of stuff works really well on
a tablet where you may want to sit down
and or indeed for Tasker where you
having to create gooeys and those sorts
of things like that on my phone not so
much that on a tablet well I think we'd
all kind of like to be able to write
code on a tablet maybe this is a first
step giving yourself a little more space
is always a good thing well the one
thing you should also remember when
you're going between tablets and phones
is that most people have both devices if
they have a tablet they almost certainly
have a phone absolutely and so being
able to create something on one device
and use it on another device we're on
all of your devices also a feature I
would really like to see absolutely I
guess the other side of that community
repository I want my own repository and
go like I've created it I want to apply
this to all of my devices exactly really
nice all right so before we sign off
let's take a look at our prescriptions
for each app to help them move towards a
pure Android experience do we put that
in scare quotes I think until we
actually launched it yes no problem then
we lose the scan quits awesome alright
so the the prescription we have four
Tasker is first a UI makeover and I
think it needs one it deserves one it's
a wonderful program and it'd be nice if
it is so short like it you know it's a
great app with huge amounts of
functionality it just looks like it's
old and you know give it the hollow
makeover exactly and lose the dialogues
more than anything else this is what
makes the program hard to use and it
puts you in a very modal position so
it's difficult to quickly edit things
because you have to jump in and out of
modes I'd love to see a tablet version
where I could see multiple conditions
multiple contacts and multiple tasks all
laid out where I could tweak each one of
them that would be beautiful they
definitely need a repository the wiki is
awesome but only if you're willing to
really work it something some of the
competitors out there actually have
something where the first thing you do
is press button or even you don't even
need to press a button you to see
popular
pastor popular contacts and popular
profiles that other people have defined
and it turns out when I went looking
that everything that I wanted to do had
already been defined and all that I need
to do is change the location or change
the time aerials so let's let's get that
in I think that if if that was in the
app it would be a winner it would be
hands down my favorite profile app I but
finally I think that you could have a
little bit more appropriate feature
discovery things like variables that are
very important like if I want to see
what speed i'm going for instance are
very difficult to discover you have to
drill all the way in to a condition and
then sometimes you have to type in the
variable name but sometimes you can
select it from a list and that's very
very odd especially since there are
about a hundred different built-in
variables that lets you check different
things on your phone it's really really
nice but then again you've got the
scenes feature which is an app built
it's an IDE which most of the users of
this particular application will
probably not use it's an it feature and
yet it's given a very prominent position
on the very first page so it's not about
making things more or less discoverable
it's making them more appropriately
discoverable that makes a lot of sense
for NFC task launcher I like I said it
they've actually done a lot of the
things that I was hoping for I think
there is still a little bit of work to
be done in navigation and that's maybe
something that you guys can find out
exactly if I if I am a one-off que sirve
a lot of people having the same problems
using analytics find out how many times
people are accidentally exiting out of
your appt don't put up but are you sure
you want to exit dialogue that's right
that's a solution that is just an
indication that your navigation is more
confusing than it needs to be I'd love
to see icons for my tags because they
look really nice on that front page you
know the icons exist i copied a profile
which had an icon associated with it so
having those they're available for my
own have to be really nice avoid what
I've said here is avoid duplicate evacs
ins because when I wrote this I thought
that finish and done did the same thing
as it turns out they don't so do check
out the way that up affordances are
supposed to work and make sure that
that's consistent with the way that the
platform has been designed and in
general try to avoid using
herbs as app titles because they will
show up as if they were buttons to a lot
of people absolutely even even
experienced Android users like myself
can get confused indeed and also taking
a leaf out of out of profile widget
they've done a really nice job
customizing their toasts I've seen other
apps which have really rich
notifications so we do use both of those
things in this app to notify you that
the profile has changed so maybe you
spend a little bit of the awesome design
work that you've done throughout the
rest of the app just to make those final
couple of pieces a little bit more
polish but remember for those of you at
home watching this do not make toasts
for any other reason host to say please
don't press that button again no this is
this is a perfect example of where
toasts are useful and are appropriate
right because it's a because it's a
short-lived notification it's a
notification you need to be notified if
you're paying attention you do not need
to be notified later you do not need the
notification to persist and you don't
need to pop up its own activity exactly
a good good job that they've done here
as well as that both toast and
notifications are optional so it doesn't
necessary if you don't want to have
anything pop up or appear in your
notification tray it won't and the last
app in a profile widget it's a little
bit simplest we don't have as much
feedback really make that getting
started as simple as possible if you
take a leaf out of some of the other
apps here particularly NFC task launcher
to say well here are the most common
things you press this button once and
make that part of the flow so when I
dropped the widget onto the home screen
basically just give me a list of either
existing or new profiles that I want to
associate with it so that it's click
click done and then I can worry about
customizing and everything afterwards
what I need to understand how it works
as quickly as I can and maybe revisit
the dashboard pattern particularly
because even on a phone if I rotated
into landscape mode it doesn't fit I end
up doing mini scrolling which is a
little uncomfortable so that is all for
us today don't forget to tune into room
and Nick and Adam for Android design in
action that next tuesday when hopefully
they'll be sitting there design skills
loose on some of the apps we looked at
today absolutely we'll be back again
next week to look at sleep monitoring
apps which will make an
change from having in monitoring my
sleep every evening which is getting a
little creepy yeah it's also a really
difficult job and I'm very tired in the
morning yeah so if you've got a device
profile app you'd like us to take a look
at be sure when I hit out trailer page
absolutely i think we meant sleep I
sleep out though I men sleep at deal I
don't know what you said because I
wasn't I said the thing that you wrote
it was wrong the thing which we didn't
update right well yeah so you have a
sleep monitoring app or any of the other
categories we've got eBook readers
coming up in a couple of weeks there's a
whole bunch of options there to go to
bit ly / app clinic Trello and get your
votes and your self nominations in we
love to a review apps from people who
have written them and ask for us to take
a look at them it's the easiest way for
us to be able to really have an impact
on what you exactly and we've date
people calling in to complain later that
we reviewed their apps without their
permission so please don't post a nap
unless there's a way for us to get in
touch with the author absolutely so I
until then thank you for watching my
name is reto Meier and I me Andy Lewis
and this has been the app Clank thanks
for watching
you